what number sets does the number eight
belong to now before even answering that
question let's just think about the
different number sets there are there
are the real numbers
the real numbers and these are literally
all of the numbers we've been dealing
with to date
when we go to more advanced topics
you'll learn that there are such things
as imaginary and complex numbers or at
least in the mathematical sense they
exist but for now real numbers are
essentially everything that we know of
on the number line so if i were to draw
the number line right here a real number
can be represented as any point on this
number line or it's the set of all of
the points on this number line if you
just keep going in the positive
direction and you just keep going in the
negative direction it's all of these
points and it includes it includes
points it includes numbers like pi where
their decimal representation is
3.14159 it just keeps repeating on and
on and on never it cannot be represented
as a fraction or as a rational
expression it just is this decimal
expansion that just keeps goes on and on
and on and on square root of 2 is
another one that is also a real but
everything else is also so real is kind
of the broadest set of numbers we've
been dealing with now if we want to be a
little bit more restrictive we get two
rational numbers
we get to
rational numbers and the best way to
think about rational there's two ways to
think about it these are numbers
numbers that
can
be expressed
as you can see as a rational expression
or as
a
as a
fraction
as a fraction so for example
negative 1 is a rational number because
negative one could be written as
negative one over one zero is a rational
number can be expressed as zero over
anything could be zero over ten doesn't
have to be
two is a rational number one half is a
rational number all of these are
rational numbers what aren't rational
numbers are numbers like square root of
2 or 3.14 or pi or e these numbers that
cannot be represented as a fraction so
you can imagine that the rational
numbers it's kind of like the set of
real numbers maybe i write it like this
it's the set of real numbers
minus if you were to take out if you
were to take out irrational numbers
you would take out irrational
take out irrational numbers and these
are like so for example we have things
like pi
e these are actual numbers you know
3.1415
e is you know between 2 and 3 square
root of 2. we can go on and on and on
there's an infinite number of irrational
numbers so it's a little abstract but
anything that can be represented as a
fraction you definitely know is rational
now if we want to get a little bit more
restrictive than that if we just want to
deal with the numbers that aren't
fractions in the traditional sense that
are i guess we could use the word whole
numbers although we want to be careful
with that word because that could also
be considered a
a number set if we're thinking about
just the four the three the two all of
the kind of the the the
i guess you know whole numbers then we
can we're talking about the integers
we're talking about the integers
the integers so these are you know we
could just go from the negative
direction you know maybe negative 2
negative 1 then 0 then we get 1 2 3. i
think you get the idea it's all of the
positive and negative whole numbers and
it includes zeros if you do the integers
on this line it would be everything that
i'm doing
in orange now there's two other sets
that are subsets of integers depending
on the interpretation you you look at so
sometimes you'll hear people say whole
numbers
whole
whole numbers and this is a bit of an
ambiguous statement because sometimes
when people say whole numbers they're
referring to integers sometimes when
they're referring to whole numbers
they're referring to non-negative
integers so 0 1 2 3 sometimes they're
referring to just positive integers so 1
2 3 so on and so forth so this is a
little bit ambiguous it's a little
ambiguous i've seen it used
i've seen it used in all of those
different ways
but if someone says a whole number i
generally think of non-negative numbers
it's ambiguous but for our purposes
let's think of it as 0 1 2
so on and so forth now the last one to
consider is natural numbers
and once again this one is also
ambiguous
natural
numbers
and the reason why it's called natural
numbers are these are numbers that you
would actually encounter if you were to
either try to order things or actually
count things in nature so it it
definitely so this is also ambiguous
this is also ambiguous but it definitely
excludes
but it definitely
negative numbers negative
numbers and so if it definitely excludes
negative numbers just like why is it
ambiguous well it's ambiguous whether it
includes 0. so
sometimes 0 is natural so 0
may
or
not
be
natural depending on the context may or
may not be natural now let's answer our
actual question what number sets does 8
belong to well 8 definitely belongs to
the real numbers it is on the number
line it is definitely a rational number
we can express it as 8 over 1 or 16 over
2 or
even you know negative 8 over negative 1
i mean you could actually have
an infinite number of ways to express it
as a fraction so it's definitely a
rational number it's definitely an
integer it's a whole number
it's definitely an integer it is a whole
number i mean we're ambiguous what to
include in whole numbers but positive 8
is unambiguously a whole number it's
definitely included and it's
unambiguously a natural number if i go
out and count trees i can count eight
trees so it is a positive you know if we
if the number was zero i'd be like well
depending on who you talk to it might be
a natural number but eight definitely is
a natural number so it's a part of all
of these number sets